i'm not gonna be able to keep her cool
sorry oh gosh
welcome back i can't you know it's the
mess it died
anyway our next guest well i basically
think you know how i feel i'm losing my
mind because she's here
i'm freaking out her motto is life
is a musical she actually just turned 50
and she has never looked better
so here to bring melody into all of our
lives
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god that was the best intro ever a
way to make a girl feel great
oh debbie i'm so excited that you're
here
oh i just love you so much thank you the
feeling is mutual
i think we share that life philosophy
you know you were talking
in the news about how you never quite
feel like a grown-up and you
love that sense of play and i think as
showbiz women like
we've been given permission to play
dress-up and play characters
and keep this whimsical attitude about
life and
i feel like everyone can bring that into
their own life especially like this past
year has been
hard and i think we we all need to kind
of develop some kind of philosophy to
flip the script and you know kind of
just uh lighten things up so yes that is
my philosophy
well and your motto about life is a
musical you had a video that went viral
and i think not only do you have this
great attitude
and you're right about giving ourselves
an excuse to be playful
but you can even bring it into
you know everyday chores and everyday
life and
it just makes everything so hopeful
hopeful let's roll the clip
i want everyone to see this
you be mine you guys hanging in
i mean i just love that there are
certain things in life that kind of
produce that frown mentality like it's
things that we have to do
and you're approaching it like this well
i just remember the day that i did that
because you know i deal with some health
issues and i think
everyone this past year if you've had
pre-existing issues
or if you didn't you developed them
because it was just a hard year for
everybody in their own way i am a solo
female i live by myself which i actually
love but you know i was i was kind of
curled up in a ball that day and i was
like i need to get unstuck i allow
myself to feel
every feeling that i have to feel but
then i go all right i can now either
continue spiraling down or i can
spiral up and i thought oh wouldn't it
be funny if i just put on the flashiest
most expensive pair of heels i have to
do the trash this trash day
and film it and that's where social
media can actually be a great
thing because now people look for it on
mondays i don't do it every monday but
people started to look for it and
they're like
i wonder what she's gonna wear next or
what you get and and so it really is a
case that we can lift each other up and
yes you can take some mundane tasks
and make it a great happy thing well
what about this next clip
um let me show it and then tell me about
it
do you know what time it is everybody
it's time to mop
[Music]
i will never look at a swiffer the same
oh my god so those are my tap shoes that
i've had since i'm like 14 and they're
falling apart
and the same thing i'm like all right
let's just infuse a little humor
into again what can be such a
you know a grind so yeah i just feel
like you know i remember when joan
rivers was alive who i just loved she
said
similarly like if you look at your life
like it's a movie and you kind of
observe it from the outside it becomes
comical the things that could be so
painful
that you can put a comical spin on them
because you know
i think i think one thing i've learned
through getting older and evolving is
stuff's going to continue to happen and
it's how you handle it